bonjour vous allez bien
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
François-Xavier Bellamy bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous député
européen membre des républicains on est
ensemble pendant un peu plus de 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représentée par Fabrice wesser Redon du
groupe Ebra bonjour Fabrice bonjour
bonjour
de l'Est de la France on va évidemment
parler de votre partie en
François-Xavier Bellamy votre candidat
Bruno Retailleau et donc qualifié pour
le second tour en deuxième position mais
moins de 10 points le sépare d'Éric
Ciotti arrive en tête c'est une bonne
surprise
oui ça n'est pas vraiment une surprise
pour nous parce que c'est le résultat
d'une dynamique que nous avons constaté
partout sur sur le terrain depuis les
dernières semaines autour de Bruno
Retailleau et puis avec toute l'équipe
qui l'entoure nous sommes déployés dans
toute la France pour aller à la
rencontre des adhérents des républicains
et au fond ce que je retire de ce
scrutin du vote d'hier c'est que comme
nous l'avions perçu comme nous l'avions
entendu comme nous le pensions aussi
profondément il y a aujourd'hui un
besoin profond de renouvellement et si
nous sommes engagé si je me suis engagé
autour de Bruno Retailleau depuis le
premier jour c'est pour dire que si la
droite veut survivre elle doit tout
changer elle doit tout refonder et que
ce renouvellement est absolument
impératif nous ne sommes pas dans une
élection ordinaire où on pourrait
imaginer continuer le travail comme
d'habitude aujourd'hui les républicains
sont dans un moment j'allais dire de
survie encore une fois et je crois
qu'ils doivent survivre et ils doivent
se reconstruire pas pour eux-mêmes pas
pour
prolonger une étiquette une boutique un
appareil mais parce que qui compte
derrière la reconstruction de ce parti
c'est la reconstruction de la droite
pour redonner à la France une majorité
la majorité politique dont elle a besoin
pour pouvoir se relever et on va parler
évidemment longuement de tout ça
parce Bruno Retailleau quand il a pris
la parole il a dit la bonne nouvelle
c'est qu'il y a un second tour ça veut
dire que vous en doutiez comment il a
accueilli ces résultats donc on en
doutait pas mais c'est vrai que jusqu'au
jour même de l'élection tous ceux qui
observent ce scrutin avec un peu de
recul nous disait de toute façon c'est
déjà fait ça va se jouer au premier tour
ce sera fini et finalement cette
élection elle était écrite d'avance
c'est ce qu'on nous prémettait depuis le
depuis le début de cette campagne est-ce
qu'on voit c'est qu'il n'en est rien il
y a un second tour vous l'avez dit
l'écart entre les deux candidats il est
relativement faible c'est un écart de
5000 voix et donc nous avons devant nous
une semaine et une semaine pour
convaincre et je crois surtout encore
une fois si on prend en compte le
résultat de chaque candidat si on si on
prend en compte le résultat d'Aurélien
pradique qui avait fait sa campagne sur
cette volonté de changement et bien on
voit qu'il y a aujourd'hui une majorité
d'adhérents qui sont largement
convaincus qu'il est nécessaire de de
vivre ce renouvellement profond pour
pouvoir se reconstruire justement
Aurélien Pradier arrivée troisième quels
sont les arguments qui font que vous
pourriez mobiliser que Bruno Retailleau
pourrait mobiliser ces électeurs là
d'abord nous on parle à tous les
adhérents de la droite et puis on est
dans une élection interne donc on n'a
pas évidemment on a des concurrents
comme dans toute élection mais on n'a
pas d'adversaire politique et moi je
voudrais dire à la fin de ce premier
tour d'abord la joie que nous avons que
cette élection se soit déroulée de
manière paisible de manière sereine et
puis mon respect bien sûr et mon amitié
pour aussi bien pour pour relier un
Pradier que pour quels sont les points
de programme qui vous payent je crois
que ce qui compte
à rassembler à refaire l'unité Bruno
retailleux elle a dit hier les divisions
nous ont trop coûté et je crois que
c'est c'est déjà dans ce second tour
aussi l'enjeu l'enjeu de ce de ce
rassemblement Aurélien Pradier je crois
que ce qui a fait que des électeurs se
sont tournés vers lui c'est c'est ce
besoin de renouvellement ce besoin d'un
bar renouvellement sur le fond il l'a
dit la nécessité d'une droite qui ne se
qui ne se coupent pas des plus modestes
et je crois que c'est aussi au cœur de
notre de notre engagement au cœur de mon
engagement depuis le début de de mon
engagement en politique je crois que
c'est effectivement important de de
redonner à la droite le sens de sa
responsabilité à l'égard de tous les
Français a commencé par les plus
fragiles à commencer par les plus
vulnérables et puis le deuxième grand
argument d'Aurélien Pradier dans sa
campagne c'était le renouvellement
générationnel Aurélien Pradier l'avait
dit d'ailleurs d'une manière assez forte
dans le débat par exemple on voit
aujourd'hui autour de nous tous les
partis politiques qui finalement passent
le témoin de jeunes générations et
Aurélien Pradier faisait de sa
candidature l'occasion de se
renouvellement
telle responsabilité dans l'hypothèse
cette dimension de renouvellement
générationnel et bien je crois qu'elle
est aussi présente dans la campagne de
Bono retailleux Bruno c'est le seul
candidat d'une certaine manière qui a
fait campagne de manière déterminée
depuis le premier jour avec une équipe
autour de lui une équipe qui qu'il met
en avant j'en fais en m'occupant de la
refondation comme Othman Nasro comme
Julien Aubert comme Bretagne
parce qu'il en a fait son marqueur
souvenez-vous dès le début de cette
campagne alors que finalement on pensait
que cette élection allait être déjà
installée et bien Bruno Retailleau avec
courage il faut bien le dire à apporter
dans le débat la nécessité de faire de
cette élection l'occasion de tout
refonder il avait écrit un livre qui
porte ce titre refondation il y a
plusieurs années et je l'ai toujours vu
animé par cette volonté de recommencer
tout depuis les fondations il avait
promis même de construire un nouveau
parti et je crois que ce renouvellement
profond on en a besoin il l'a montré en
disant au cours de cette campagne qu'il
était temps par exemple de tourner la
page avec ceux qui a commencé par
Nicolas Sarkozy qui la redit hier
voudrait nous entraîner dans une
coalition avec Emmanuel Macron nous
pouvons avoir évidemment
la fierté d'assumer les belles pages de
l'histoire de notre famille politique
qui a parfois réussi des choses
importante pour la France dans dans son
histoire souvent mais mais nous devons
reconnaître aussi que si la droite
aujourd'hui est dans une situation de
crise et si la France est dans une
situation de crise c'est probablement
parce que la droite n'a pas non plus
tout réussi quand elle était au
responsabilité assumer cela faire de ce
devoir de lucidité l'occasion de renouer
avec les Français et de retrouver leur
confiance c'est le débat responsabilité
dans l'état
que Bruno Retailleau a porté c'est donc
non pas pour non pas pour critiquer ou
pour attaquer de manière stérile mais
seulement pour que nous puissions
retrouver une ligne claire et cette
ligne claire qui nous a parfois manqué
est-ce que c'est aussi l'unité du parti
qui se joue le week-end prochain oui je
le disais il faut qu'on arrive à réussir
ce rassemblement qui est absolument
nécessaire et Bruno retailleul a rappelé
hier dans son dans son intervention
du parti si ericky l'emporte en tous les
cas ce qui est absolument certain c'est
que si nous nous divisons nous n'aurons
aucune chance de survivre nous sommes
dans un moment où nous sortons cette
année présidentielle législative avec
des résultats extrêmement
marquants qui montrent l'ampleur de la
crise que nous traversons si nous
voulons avoir une chance de nous relever
nous avons absolument le devoir de
non je crois pas vous voyez moi je serai
pas de ceux qui vous seriez en agitant
une peur vous seriez prêt à travailler
avec Éric je le redis c'est très
important nous sommes dans une campagne
interne nous avons des concurrents mais
nous n'avons pas d'adversaires
politiques nos adversaires politiques
Bruno retailleux l'a rappelé nous
adversaires politiques qui sont à gauche
ils sont
chez la majorité qui on va certainement
en parler qui est tellement responsable
de de la de la crise dans laquelle notre
pays sans Lise aujourd'hui nous ne
confondons pas nos concurrents dans
cette élection interne avec avec les
lignes politiques préoccupantes pour
l'avenir de la France qu'il nous faut
combattre à l'extérieur de notre part
entre les deux pendant cette semaine
d'entre deux tours ce qui va se jouer
c'est une question de ligne c'est une
question de personnalité qu'est-ce qui
va faire l'élection second tour selon
vous je crois ce qui compte c'est
d'abord les idées plus que les personnes
on sait trop peut-être à droite on s'est
trop abîmés dans dans les dans les dans
les querelles d'ego Bruno Retailleau
avait d'ailleurs dans ce livre fondation
expliqué la nécessité justement de
de sortir de ce tout-à-l'égo dans lequel
la droite était souvent rentrée ce qui
compte c'est de c'est de retrouver le
sens des idées le sens d'une ligne
claire d'une vision pour l'avenir de la
France d'une vision aussi pour l'avenir
de la droite mais une si grande
différence que ça d'entre les lignes
directions et entre la ligne d'érections
parce que nous sommes dans le même parti
mais oui je crois qu'il y a des
différences d'approche et notamment dans
la manière de reconstruire ce parti ce
que Bruno Retailleau propose c'est de
redonner la parole aux militants de de
faire un parti qui soit vraiment
démocratique un parti moderne un parti
qui assume le débat en son sein et puis
surtout en partie qui aille chercher
dans ses adhérents le courage et la
clarté qui ont parfois manqué à sa ligne
nationale moi je suis convaincu que dans
les débats passés que nous avons pu
avoir ou parfois notre famille politique
à montrer l'exemple de quelques
incohérences qui ont coûté à sa
crédibilité on aurait eu plus de clarté
on aurait eu plus de force si on s'était
tourné vers les électeurs de droite ce
que nous voulons dire à tous les
électeurs de droite c'est que c'est avec
eux que nous reconstruirons ce parti en
allant vraiment me tourner vers eux à
travers des référendums nous sommes le
parti gaulliste nous croyons à
l'autorité du chef mais nous croyons
aussi à l'efficacité du référendum avec
des référendums internes pour trancher
des débats majeurs qui permettent
ensuite d'aboutir à une ligne claire qui
s'impose à tous mais aussi de pouvoir à
travers nos investitures associées les
élus de terrain associés les cadres de
terrain pour que nous puissions avoir
les meilleures candidats possibles et
donc demain avoir plus de victoires
de candidats au bureau politique en
commission d'investiture les militants
seront systématiquement consultés ça
veut dire que le parti va faire son
travail mais nous avons été chercher
avec avec Julien Aubert qui travaille
avec moi sur la refondation des exemples
de fonctionnement des grands partis de
droite en Europe qui fonctionnent encore
bien et qui ont beaucoup d'adhérents
prenez la Cedeo prenez le parti de
popular en Allemagne en Espagne ce sont
des parties dans lesquelles il y a une
commission d'investiture nationale mais
les adhérents peuvent aussi
apporter leur voix en décidant de
soutenir un candidat alternatif et je
crois que c'est la garantie pour que un
parti respire pour que ce parti demain
de nouveau ressemble à ces adhérents
pour que ce parti respecte tous les
électeurs de droite il faut qu'il les
mettent au cœur de son propre
fonctionnement de rester indépendants
est-ce que les républicains peuvent
rester indépendants où est-ce que
l'avenir des républicains passe
forcément par une alliance et de quel
côté si c'est le cas mais on n'a pas
seulement la possibilité de rester
indépendante on en a le devoir le devoir
de défendre la ligne qui je le crois et
tout le vérifier aujourd'hui et la seule
qui peut sortir la France de la crise
qu'elle traverse sur les questions
migratoires sur les questions d'énergie
d'industrie sur les questions de
politique éducative la droite dit
aujourd'hui ce dont la France a j'en
suis convaincu besoin et donc notre
devoir c'est de ne pas renoncer à nos
convictions pour je ne sais quelle
arrangement électoral c'est cela qui a
dégouté les Français de la politique la
droite a le devoir de retrouver cette
constance cette clarté et comment
voulez-vous ces électeurs qui sont soit
chez Marine Le Pen soit chez man Macron
et bien justement en leur disant que
c'est avec eux que nous allons
reconstruire une famille politique qui
puisse les représenter en disant nous
avons perdu 10 millions d'électeurs 10
millions et donc la question c'est ce
que Bruno Retailleau a dit pendant toute
cette campagne est-ce que nous
continuons de dire que nous avons tout
bien réussi et que c'est eux qui ont mal
compris ou bien est-ce que nous nous
tournons vers eux pour leur demander ce
qu'ils attendent de nous nous avons le
sentiment que ceux qui le veulent c'est
une ligne de droite clair assumée
franche et je crois que c'est avec eux
que nous reconstruirons cette vision
courageuse et ambitieuse qui permettra
demain à notre pays de se sortir de la
crise parce que c'est ça l'enjeu le
sujet c'est pas de reconstruire un parti
je n'ai pas une vocation
passionnée de d'hommes de parties ce qui
compte pour moi c'est de sortir la
France de l'impasse dans laquelle elle
est aujourd'hui de cet impact politique
mais aussi de cet impact démocratique
qui a abouti à ce que aujourd'hui la
réalité de la France c'est ça il y a
jamais eu autant d'électeurs de droite
en France il y a jamais eu aussi peu
d'électeurs qui ont voté pour le parti
qui est chargé de les représenter parce
que ce parti leur a manqué et la
question qui se pose aujourd'hui c'est
comment est-ce que nous allons sortir de
cette situation dans laquelle un
président minoritaire gouverne avec des
gens de gauche un pays qui est à droite
mais vous vous parlez de droite assumée
est-ce que les républicains doivent
rester un parti de la droite et du sang
ou est-ce qu'il faut assumer la rupture
et dire désormais on est un parti de
droite moi j'ai aucun intérêt pour ces
questions d'étiquettes qui comptent pour
moi c'est
de ligne aussi est-ce que vous continuez
à vous tourner vers les centristes ou
est-ce que pour être un parti de droite
assumée il faut dire et bien les
républicains ne font plus d'alliance
avec le Centre encore une fois je le
redis la question c'est quel est le
contenu vous avez des gens qui se disent
centrist et qui sont partis soutenir
Emmanuel Macron je vois pas très bien
d'ailleurs ce qui Emmanuel Macron a de
cent triste en réalité par beaucoup
d'aspects l'histoire du centrisme dans
notre pays c'est par exemple l'histoire
de la décentralisation c'est l'histoire
de la responsabilité des collectivités
locales Emmanuel Macron est celui qui
aura recentralisé comme jamais en
mettant presque sous tutelle les
communes en les privant de leur liberté
fiscale ce qui est une sorte de rupture
avec un
héritage presque millénaire celui de la
libre administration communale je on
voit pas très bien ce qu'il y a de
centriste mais passons des gens qui
voulaient se placer dans les allées du
pouvoir ont été chez Emmanuel Macron
grand bien leur face ce que nous disons
c'est que aujourd'hui le débat est clair
tous ceux qui pensent qu'il faut
soutenir Emmanuel Macron ils ont un
parti pour ça ça s'appelle la République
en marche et qu'ils viennent de la
droite du cendre de n'importe où ils
peuvent se retrouver dans cette
formation politique ça s'appelle la
majorité mais nous nous resterons dans
l'opposition et dans l'opposition avec
tous ceux qui veulent défendre justement
une éducation nationale qui ne se met
pas au service des idéologies de la
déconstruction tous ceux qui veulent
défendre un rétablissement de nos
finances publiques tous ceux qui veulent
défendre le retour au principe de
subsidiarité la liberté enfin rendu aux
Français sur le terrain tous ceux qui
veulent défendre une politique
migratoire forte et ferme et d'une
certaine manière d'où qu'il vienne quel
que soit les noms qu'il se donnent avec
eux nous devons travailler bien sûr dans
notre délégation au Parlement européen
nous travaillons avec évidemment des
élus LR et puis sur notre liste il y
avait par exemple Nathalie Colin
austerlit qui est vient du parti des
centristes avec Hervé Morin qui est
surprenante de notre délégation qui
contribue pleinement qui travaillent sur
les questions qui touchent notamment à
la santé et sur ces sujets là et bien je
crois donc il faut garder le centre sur
la ligne politique générale que nous
défendons ensemble nous n'avons jamais
eu de désaccords majeurs et encore une
fois je le redis le vrai sujet c'est pas
les étiquettes le vrai sujet c'est les
idées c'est le fond c'est le contenu et
moi je ne fais pas mystère du fait que
je suis de droite je veux que la famille
politique de la droite assume une ligne
politique de droite parce que c'est ce
qu'on attend d'elle et que c'est à force
de zigzaguer qu'elle a fini par perdre
sa crédibilité pour le reste demain tous
ceux qui veulent reconstruire autour de
cette ligne clair et une majorité pour
la France nous travaillerons avec eux
Eric Zemmour vous a à nouveau tendu la
main hier il fêtait les un an de son
parti reconquête en parlant de la faire
Lola ou du des migrants de la chaîne
Viking il a dit il fallait que Bruno
retaille au Fula toute la droite aurait
dû être présente l'Union des droites
c'est un chemin est-ce que c'est un
chemin qu'il faut emprunter selon vous
j'ai du mal à comprendre en réalité je
vous le dis comme je le pense j'ai du
mal à comprendre j'ai lu La Tribune que
que Eric Zemmour a publié il y a
quelques jours dans dans le Figaro ce
que j'ai du mal à comprendre c'est qu'on
parle d'union des droites tout en tout
en faisant vivre des des
[Musique]
parties des écuries là encore justement
des étiquettes différentes quand il
l'écrit dans le Figaro qu'il faut faire
l'union des droites
Eric Zemmour qui voudrait j'imagine se
tourner vers les électeurs de Marine Le
Pen et des républicains dit que Marine
Le Pen incarne le socialisme mariniste
et que les républicains sont condamnés à
tomber vers la gauche donc je ne sais
pas exactement dans lequel dans quelle
équation
s'inscrit cette cette
problème c'est qu'il s'inscrit dans une
dans une question de partie c'est à dire
que si vous avez si il dit dans ces
cas-là moi je vous rejoins vous acceptez
que
Eric Zemmour
qui est que c'est justement le parti de
la droite le parti qui historiquement à
la mission de représenter la droite qui
doit se reconstruire pour réunir de
nouveaux tous les électeurs de droite
c'est exactement ce que nous disons avec
Bruno retenu sans jeter sans jeter
danathème gratuit c'est la raison pour
laquelle Bruno Retailleau a été le seul
de tous les candidats qui effectivement
n'a pas souhaité rentrer dans cette
espèce de de surenchère complètement
artificiel lorsque le député de Fournas
s'est exprimé à l'Assemblée nationale
nous nous notre but c'est non pas de
rentrer dans des logiques d'appareil je
le redis ça n'est pas une question
d'étiquette de partie qui devrait
s'additionner c'est une question de
ligne claire et autour d'une ligne
claire on pourra réunir tous les
électeurs une ligne qui pourrait
englober des élections comme des
électeurs qui ont voté pour Emmanuel
des républicains quel nom vous avez
envie de lui donner je ne sais pas je
n'en sais rien et je vais vous dire
finalement c'est peut-être la chose la
moins importante il faudra certainement
bien sûr mais à la fin ce qui compte
c'est le contenu plus que l'apparence un
dernier mot avant de parler de la
présidentielle Xavier Bertrand a
confirmé qu'il allait soutenir Bono
Retailleau vous avez il vous l'a dit je
ne crois pas que ce soit exprimé
publiquement c'est pour ça que je vous
demande
je crois pas que ce soit exprimé
publiquement il y a une semaine d'entre
deux tours on verra les expressions des
uns des autres mais c'est pas moi de
c'est pas à moi de parler au nom de qui
que ce soit vous parliez de la
d'organisation du parti c'était
important pour une heureuse année on a
beaucoup par
lé de parler de la présidentielle
justement fabriquée
il faut s'intéresser tout de suite à la
présidentielle il faut s'intéresser tout
de suite à la présidentielle parce que
se reconstruire maintenant c'est se
donner le plus de chances de recréer
demain une majorité pour la France et ça
se jouera évidemment dans une élection
présidentielle on peut pas se contenter
d'être comme on l'est aujourd'hui un
parti très fort au niveau local on doit
aussi faire de cette force locale de cet
atout indispensable l'occasion de
reconstruire une majorité nationale en
revanche je crois ce serait une très
grande erreur de penser que se
préoccuper de la présidentielle c'est
désigner tout de suite un candidat on
parle cette position là immédiatement le
renvoie ne s'est pas placer aujourd'hui
dans un agenda de candidature et
d'ailleurs je crois que c'est très
important de respecter son choix il a
décidé de ne pas prendre la présidence
de notre parti politique pour aller à la
rencontre des Français d'une autre
manière c'est ainsi qu'il le dit moi je
crois et Bruno retailleul a dit à de
nombreuses reprises que leur envoiier à
toutes les qualités pour être demain
notre candidat mais ce que nous pouvons
faire le mieux pour lui c'est pas de le
désigner dans trois mois alors que
lui-même a souhaité prendre de la
hauteur et aller sur le terrain d'une
manière un peu différente si nous avons
évident que ça doit être lui en 2027
pourquoi ne pas le dire clairement ce
que nous avons de mieux à faire ça n'est
pas de lui mettre une cible dans le dos
qu'il va devoir ensuite porter pendant 4
ans ça n'est pas de le mettre au centre
de toutes les tensions politiques que
peut représenter le statut d'un candidat
à la présidentielle ce que nous pouvons
faire de mieux pour lui ce que nous
pouvons faire de mieux pour gagner la
présidentielle demain c'est reconstruire
ce parti comme une machine de guerre qui
pourra gagner des élections et il faut
tout recommencer depuis le début ce
parti encore une fois je le redis il
doit tout renouveler ses méthodes ces
manières de travailler il faut créer un
média pour s'adresser aux Français il
faut renforcer notre présence sur les
réseaux sociaux il faut inventer une
stratégie pour renouveler notre manière
de dire nos convictions pas changer sur
le fond mais changer peut-être dans
notre expression la façon dont nous
allons parler aux Français et le jour où
nous aurons fait ce travail là et bien
ce jour-là nous serons prêts à propulser
notre candidat Nicolas Sarkozy était
évidemment très préoccupé de sa
candidature à l'élection présidentielle
dans le deuxième quinquennat de Jacques
Chirac pourtant il ne sait pas lui-même
investi candidat 4 ans avant la
présidentielle il a attendu un an avant
et je crois que c'est assez sage nous ce
que nous proposons c'est exactement la
même méthode que celle qui a conduit
notre famille politique à la victoire en
2007 c'est que les militants propulsent
notre candidat au moment où il le
souhaitera au moment où cela sera
opportun un an avant l'élection
présidentielle quand nous aurons
vraiment un parti en ordre de marche
près à s'engager derrière lui et ça ça
suppose de mettre les étapes les unes
après les autres dans l'ordre le plus le
plus efficace quelques questions
d'actualité pour terminer
François-Xavier Bellamy puisqu’emmanuel
Macron de retour des États-Unis où il a
critiqué le choix de Joe Biden de mettre
en place une subvention dans les
industries américaines en défavorisant
l'Union européenne Emmanuel Macron dit
qu'il faut subventionner le made in
Europe est-ce que vous êtes favorable à
ça est-ce que vous me soutenez mais il
faut évidemment et c'est d'ailleurs l'un
des points que nous avions défendu dès
le début de notre mandat au Parlement
européen dès notre campagne européenne
il faut l'équivalent du buy American
actiful un acte européen qui privilégie
l'achat européen et c'est évidemment
indispensable je crois que les Français
ne peuvent pas comprendre aujourd'hui
que alors que toutes les grandes
puissances mondiales les États-Unis la
Chine subventionnent leurs production
industrielle alors qu'en Chine il est
évidemment impossible pour une
entreprise européenne de prendre un
marché public qu'on autorise des
entreprises chinoises à prendre des
marchés publics en France dans une
naïveté totale et donc ce ce choix de
sortir de la naïveté il est temps de le
faire enfin mais ce que j'observe c'est
qu'Emmanuel Macron fait partie au
Parlement européen du groupe des
libéraux c'est le groupe qui a interdit
par dogme de la concurrence qui a
interdit pendant des années pendant des
décennies qu'on sorte de cette naïveté
et c'est le même Emmanuel Macron qui
nous disait il y a encore quelques
années souvenez-vous que le
protectionnisme c'est la guerre bien je
crois que encore une fois si le
président de la République
se réveillent c'est une bonne nouvelle
non pas pour aller reprocher aux
États-Unis de soutenir leur production
industrielle mais pour que nous
puissions nous donner nous aussi les
moyens de ce travail désormais urgent
dans les Yann c'est également exprimée
là-dessus elle dit qu'il faut que
l'Union européenne doit réagir face aux
distorsion de concurrence causée par ce
plan d'investissement américain mais que
peut-elle faire il est encore temps
d'agir pour vous mais d'abord il faut
effectivement mieux protéger notre
marché c'est je crois une condition
absolue nous avons déjà à gagner une
bataille sur ce sujet puisque là encore
c'était une promesse de campagne la taxe
carbone à l'entrée du marché unique elle
a été votée par le Parlement européen
elle va rentrer en vigueur c'est pour la
première fois une protection de notre
marché intérieur et puis évidemment le
deuxième aspect c'est que il est temps
et là c'est un message que je voudrais
envoyer aussi à Ursula fan d'arlayenne
et à la Commission européenne il est
temps qu'on sorte de cette situation
délirante dans laquelle on continue à
produire des normes à produire des
contraintes à compliquer la vie de ceux
qui produisent en Europe alors qu'on est
à la veille d'une crise économique
industrielle sociale absolument majeur
on voit très bien ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui entre l'Europe et les
États-Unis les États-Unis donnent à
leurs entreprises des subventions nous
leur donnons de la régulation ça ne peut
pas marcher comme ça dans un moment où
la crise de l'énergie va avoir un impact
industriel majeur il faut absolument là
encore qu'on sorte de cette impasse et
justement en parlant de la crise de
l'énergie le gouvernement met en place
des scénaris pour faire face à
d'éventuelles coupures en raison de la
baisse de production électrique hier
Emmanuel Macron dans Le Parisien
s’évoluera sur en pas de panique dit-il
ça vous a rassuré alors moi les les
messages rassurants du président de la
République je les prends avec recul
parce que souvenez-vous quand même que
en juillet dernier en juillet dernier
Emmanuel Macron disait alors même que
les Allemands étaient en train de
préparer leur plan de délestage à eux
Emmanuel Macron disait il n'y aura pas
de coupure d'électricité en France d'une
manière absolument catégorique en
expliquant que ne vous inquiétez pas
tout ira très bien si on manque
d'électricité on ira chercher sur le
marché européen aujourd'hui on voit que
le marché européen n'est pas la solution
il est même à bien des égards un
problème et donc il faut absolument
qu'on se prépare le grand problème
évidemment le grand problème
cette coupure de courant qu'on nous
annonce déjà pour pour janvier qui
devait se se présenter elle n'est pas
liée à la guerre en Ukraine il faut le
dire avec force il y a deux ans au
Parlement européen j'avais dit que nous
connaîtrions des coupures d'électricité
en Europe et en France en particulier
pourquoi parce qu'il faisait de regarder
l'incurie de nos dirigeants qui ont
baissé la production d'électricité
pilotable depuis plusieurs années sans
rien construire sans investir sans
produire de solution qui puisse
compléter ce qu'ils étaient en train de
retirer au réseau on a fermé Fessenheim
et on n'a rien ajouté on peut faire de
l'éolien et de solaire autant qu'on
voudra on peut même couvrir la France
d'éolienne la vérité c'est que demain
même si on couvre la France d'éolienne
ça ne répond pas aux problèmes parce que
quand il y a pas de vent et généralement
quand il fait très froid il y a pas de
vent quand il y a pas de vent du tout et
bien il y a aucune éolienne qui
fonctionne donc il faut absolument
reconstruire des capacités pilotables et
la France de Monsieur Macron celle dans
laquelle le message du gouvernement qui
est une
d'une manière le bilan du macronisme
résumé en trois termes je baisse
j'éteins je décale c'est le message du
gouvernement je baise j'éteins je décale
c'est ça la France d'Emmanuel Macron
c'est la France de l'imprévoyance c'est
la France dans laquelle on a détruit nos
capacités de production sans se donner
les moyens de prévoir ce qui allait
survenir comme conséquence des choix
politiques qui ont été faits depuis 10
ans cette situation terrible encore une
fois moi ce que je trouve catastrophique
dans la déclaration d'Emmanuel Macron
c'est quand il dit nous sommes tous
responsables d'éviter les coupures de
courant la première responsabilité elle
revient à lui elle revient à ses
gouvernements successifs et je crois
qu'il faut quand même le rappeler
dernière question rapidement sur le
covid puisque la 9e vague et là est-ce
qu'il faut réintégrer les soignants non
vaccinés selon vous oui je l'ai dit je
crois que d'ailleurs c'était tout à fait
fascinant de voir il y a quelques jours
à l'Assemblée nationale que tous les
groupes d'opposition étaient unis et que
le gouvernement a tenté d'éviter ce vote
par des manœuvres de procédures toutes
les oppositions le disent pourquoi parce
que au fond aujourd'hui nous voyons bien
à quel point nous sommes dans une
situation intenable il y a un droit du
travail en France soit les gens ont
commis une faute et il faut les
licencier soit ils n'ont pas commis de
fautes et il faut évidemment les laisser
travailler on a des personnels
aujourd'hui des personnels soignants les
mêmes que nous avons applaudi à 20h
pendant des mois pour leur euroïsme dans
la lutte face au covid et même qui ont
été envoyés sans masse sans blues sans
moyens de protection dans les moments
les plus forts de l'épidémie qui sont
aujourd'hui encore suspendus dans une
sorte de situation que même la justice
il y a quelques jours à considérer
absolument un fondé et donc je crois
qu'il est nécessaire de faire en sorte
qu'on sorte de cette situation je je dis
très simplement que le plus irrationnel
c'est que des gens qui aujourd'hui sont
vaccinés et qui ont le covid parce que
le vaccin n'empêche pas ni d'avoir le
covid ni d'être contagieux les gens qui
sont vaccinés et qui ont le covid sont
envoyés travailler comme soignants dans
nos hôpitaux dans nos services de santé
alors que des personnels qui sont
absolument négatifs au covid eux sont
empêchés de travailler dans le moment
d'effondrement que connaît l'hôpital
public c'est sans doute absolument
le contraire de ce qu'il faudrait faire
aujourd'hui merci François-Xavier
Bellamy merci beaucoup
bonne journée